the Joe Rogan experience shot-makers we
don't shark he makes it definitely has
sleep outside the guy's dodging what's
Shaq snoring sounds like that's like a
reality show they've been real all
asleep in the room you wait for Shaq to
sleep and then you gotta go in the room
and fall asleep like think about how
long would it take you for if it was
like a game show like if Shaq is out
cold
[Music]
you got a lane next to him and it's like
a timer ready go possibly fall asleep
I'm tired I'm not though and he's 800
pounds he's 17,000 feet tall he's like
yeah this is not happening that would be
a hilarious like Fear Factor type show
try and fall asleep next to Shaq could
end up in a hotel room next to him and
play that game on accident chandeliers
clinking
[Applause]